[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bienvenue dans ces idées qui gouvernent
le monde l'Europe est-elle submergée par
par les migrants les migrations sont
devenus un sujet majeur de préoccupation
pour les Européens tant en ce qui
concerne les états que pour les
instances institutionnelles de l'Union
européenne ce qui s'est passé récemment
à l'empedoua avec l'afflux de migrants
semble appeler à se répéter si les
raisons invoquées elles sont nombreuses
n'apparaissent pas toujours pertinent il
n'en demeure pas moins que pas plus
l'Union européenne que ces États-membres
n'ont de véritable politiqu de
l'immigration en mesure de faire face à
l'explosion des demandeurs d'asile s'il
est vrai que les vagues migratoires se
sont intensifiées ces dernières ces
dernières années pardon en provenance
des zones de conflit et aussi du fait de
la pauvreté on ne peut pas dire
toutefois au regard de l'importance des
déplacements de population à l'échelle
de la planète que l'Europe est au
aujourd'hui submergé par les migrants
mais jusqu'à quand car cela se chiffre
par centaines de milliers de migrants au
sein d'une Europe qui ne dispose pas des
structures d'accueil et d'intégration
suffisantes qui ne sait quoi faire de
ces débouté du droit d'asile qui dispose
d'une police aux frontières de l'espace
Schengen Frontex bien souvent débordé
par manque d'effectifs et qui fantasme
sur des côtas socio-économiques choisis
impossibles à déterminer à cela s'ajoute
toutes les réticences individuelles et
collectives vis-à-vis de population en
provenance d'Afrique et du Moyen-Orient
la pression xénophobe de l'extrême
droite mais pas que il y a le sentiment
qui se développe actuellement de
reprendre le contrôle du peuplement
national c'est ce qui a poussé les pays
nordiques les plus libéraux à durcir
leur législation sur
l'immigration pour en parler je vous
présente mes invités Juliette mad
vous êtes ancienne ministre vous êtes
actuellement conseillère à la cour des
comptes pierre vermeren vous êtes
professeur des universités chroniqueur
au Figaro et esséiste Xavier dancour
vous êtes diplomate ancien ambassadeur
de France en Algérie François eran vous
êtes démographe vous êtes dans la grande
école de lined et vous êtes actuellement
professeur au Collège de
France
[Musique]
alors l'immigration les migrants c'est
un sujet d'absolue actualité reprendre
le contrôle des flux migratoires est-ce
un euphémisme pour dire réduire
drastiquement l'immigration à commencé
par les 140000 demandeurs d'asile
attendu en 2023 à ce sujet pour Emmanuel
Macron le n'a pas à réceptionner toute
la misère du monde pour le pape François
cela relève de l'indifférence pour
Didier lesquy directeur de l'office
français des migrations il n a jamais eu
en France autant d'immigrés par rapport
à ce panel d'interprétation qui divrait
pierre vermuren
oui dire qu'il a jamais eu autant
d'immigration c'est ce que dit lin
puisque ils ont
récemment présenté le sur trois
générations le chiffre de 19 millions
d'immigrés et de de leurs enfants
évidemment puisque le processus de de
naturalisation est à l'œuvre en France
on parle de la France c'est ça oui euh
donc ça c'est quand même des chiffres
tout à fait
conséquents le pape je n'ai pas de
qualification pour pour en parler ce que
je sais c'est que l'immigration
clandestine dont il parlait à propos de
Lampedusa c'est un épiphénomène à
l'échelle du phénomène migratoire à
direction de l'Union européenne parce
que au fond ça concerne quelques
dizaines de milliers de personnes mais
le le poids lourd de l'immigration elle
se passe de manière légale avec
l'attribution de visa et après des gens
qui s'installent légalement ou
illégalement au-delà du du du terme de
leur de leur visa euh voilà donc après
le président Macron euh effectivement il
a ça fait 6 ans maintenant qu'il est au
pouvoir
euh on ne sait pas très bien quelle est
sa politique dans le domaine mais moi je
pense qu'il est quand même tout à fait
il est bien placé pour l'être
représentatif des élite français qui ont
fait un choix économique il y a une
trentaine ou une quarantaine d'années
qui consiste finalement à promouvoir la
consommation et je pense qu'on analyse
pas très bien ce phénomène si on les
enfin on est resté très bizarrement dans
le schéma de l'immigrant travailleur qui
l'immigration du travail a été stoppée
en 1975 elle est marginale depuis en
fait maintenant on a un immigrant
consommateur et qui c'est pas à son
corps défendant je dirais puisque CIT
devenu un rouage central dans le
fonctionnement de notre économie qui
repose avant tout sur la consommation
voilà donc je dirais tout ça est vrai à
la fois alors julette madel comment vous
vous situez par rapport à cette trinité
Macron le pape
et le Saint-Esprit ah ouià je crois que
il y a deux choses importantes c'est que
mais par rapport à ces trois j'aimis
bien vous répondre justement par rapport
au pape je me cituerai d'abord je trouve
que le Pape a eu des mots attendus de la
part du du Saint-Père puisque le message
quand même ou mais benoî 16 aurait dit
le contraire mais bon mais c'est bien
pour ça que nous avons un pape François
tout à fait remarquable de par sa
capacité à appliquer à ces préceptes
politiques les principes fondamentaux du
christianisme qui sont quand même
l'accueil et le fait de tendre la main
au plus misérable que soi donc au moins
le pape François est avec son dogme
maintenant si l'on s'en tient quand même
à quand même la mission de l'Europe et
la mission de la France prenons la
question de l'asile la Convention de
Genève qui est un texte merveilleux qui
dit que nous devons donner l'asile à
toute personne persécuté il faut
l'appliquer toute la convention et rien
que la convention et mettre en face de
ces principes fondamentaux qui quand
même fond de l'Europe le pays le plus
attractif du monde en face de ces
principes fond fondamentaux il faut
quand même aussi mettre des chiffres
clairs et nous n'avons jamais connu une
telle pression migratoire en Europe et
en France même par rapport à la crise de
2015 qui était une crise importante
cette année plus 83 % de flux qui
viennent du sud vers l'Europe il y a
2500 morts dans la Méditerranée c'est
plus 83 % par rapport à l'année dernière
donc il faut le dire et il faut pas
considérer que face à cette pression
migratoire inédite le politique ne peut
rien faire moi je pense que le politique
peut beaucoup et d' rentrer après sur
cette question et d'abord l'Europe donc
la réponse doit être construite sans
démagogie sans dire que tout dépend de
la France et des frontières intérieures
de l'espace Schengen mais sans dire non
plus que tout dépend de l'Europe il faut
une volonté partagée et on va rentrer
dans le détail vous allez voir je pense
qu'il faut assumer que nous avons le
droit de choisir avec qui nous voulons
vivre alors François errand votre
Trinité migratoire alors d'abord oui
c'est vrai mais je le dis souvent je
l'ai répété que on n jamais autant
d'immigrés que maintenant en France 12 %
pour la première génération on peut
doubler si on ajoute les enfants nés en
France d'au moins un parent immigré mais
quand on dit qu'il y a 31 % c'est linade
31 % de la population adulte qui est
liée à l'immigration sur trois
générations ça a été complètement mal
compris je me souviens de le lorsque la
façon dont le Figaro a présenté le
résultat il y avait deux présentations
complètement contraires le journaliste
de base était à à la conférence de
presse de Vinc et il avait compris que
ça veut dire que il y a 31 % de
personnes qui sont soit immigrés
eux-mêmes soit enfant d'un ou deux
immigrés soit petit enfant de 1 2 3 ou
qure immigrés mais quand on regarde et
c'est ce que citait aussi le journaliste
de Figaro d'ailleurs quand on regarde
quelle est la proportion de d'adultes
qui ont leurs quatre grands-parents
immigrés c'est seulement 5 %. et même
les immigrés du Maghreb ils ne sont 20 %
à voir leurs quatre grands-parents
immigrés ça veut dire que les
populations se rapprochent au fil des
générations que les unions mixtes
progresse et que les deux
populations ne se séparent pas mais se
rapprochent globalement on ne le dit pas
assez et et et or l'éditorial du Figaro
en première page disait vous rendez
compte 31 % de des Français liés à
l'immigration sur tris générations mais
où va-on que fait le gouvernement il y
avait un un il y avait une contradiction
complète entre le journaliste
correctement informé et l'éditorialiste
qui faisait de qui qui était dans son
discours idéologique ce qu'il faut
ajouter aussi c'est que cette
progression de l'immigration de depuis
l'an 2000 c'est vraiment l'an 2000 que
ça a démarré elle est continue quel que
soit le président de la République en
exercice dire que c'est pas monsieur
Macron qui est responsable de la monté
de l'immigration ça n'est pas non plus
l'avant-dernier président ni l'avant
avant-dernier sous Sarkozi il y a une
légère baisse du rythme mais ça augmenté
donc il y a une formidable surestimation
du politique quant à ses capacités à
réguler ce phénomène parce qu'en fait
l'immigration a augmenté dans le monde
d'à peu près 60 % et on a quasiment le
même chiffre en Europe en France il a
une montée forte aussi mais qui est
plutôt de 40 % que que 60 % nous ne
sommes pas en pointe dans cette
progression qui a les bienens réels vous
voulez réagir pierre pierre vermuren par
rapport à ce qui vient d'être dit c'est
plutôt ce que disait Juliette Méadel
concernant le la poussée migratoire dont
on parle actuellement à Lampedusa pour
je vivais au Maroc dans les années 90 à
cette époque- là 200000 migrants passé
chaque année traverser le détroit de
Gibraltar la moitié était renvoyé chez
eux par la police espagnole mais c'est
dire que ces flux maintenant ils sont
très anciens il y avait déjà beaucoup de
morts à l'époque dans le D3 et le jour
du 11 septembre tout s'est arrêté la
police marocaine a repris le contrôle et
pendant plusieurs années il y a plus un
migrant qui est passé donc c'est aussi
très lié au phénomène politique et au
contrôle ou politique peut faire plein
de choses oui je voudrais avoir votre
avis sur la la Sainte Trinité que vous
évoquiez je pense que chacun est dans
son rôle chacun est dans son couloir
finalement le pape comme l'a dit Madame
Méadel on pouvait rien attendre d' autre
de lui c'est il est dans son rôle il
aurait pu le formuler différemment
disant je remercie l'Europe d'avoir fait
ce qu'elle a fait et il faut continuer
mais là bon il est allé directement sur
il faut être encore plus généreux le
président de la République bah il est
dans son rôle de dire cela quant à
Didier lesquy c'est quand même un grand
professionnel des questions
d'immigration donc vous vous Xavier
dancour vous étiez diplomate vous avez
été ambassadeur en Algérie à deux
reprises repris voilà alors je voudrais
et je suis à la cour du droit d'asile
tout à fait alors à votre avis le fait
que les politiques migratoires les
politiques d'immigration soit à la fois
de la responsabilité des traités
européens et également des politiques
nationales est-ce que c'est c'est pas
gênant pour coordonner les deux c'est g
votre point de vue de diplomate
là-dessus est-ce qu'il y a quel est-ce
que c'est inconciliable c'est gênant
pour deux raisons d'abord parce que dans
une Europe à 27 on a du mal à se mettre
d'accord avec des politiques qui sont
complètement différentes voire
divergentes aller en Estonie où leur
préoccupation c'est l'immigration russe
et c'est la population russe qui habite
en Estonie c'est pas les africains ou
les gens du Sahel et deuxièmement parce
que tout ce débat il se situe
aujourd'hui dans un contexte
international qui est ce qu'il est avec
le avec le Maghreb qui va mal et nos
relations avec ces pays-là qui vont
également mal donc c'est parfaitement
normal que la contradiction entre une
politique européenne qui se cherche et
puis des politiques nationales dont la
politique française qui est largement
quand même tourné implanté en Afrique
depuis
longtemps ça pose des des difficultés
dans l'opinion française on va rentrer
donc sur les questions d'actualité les
naufragé en mer Méditerranée entraîne
des centaines de morts les pays comme
l'Italie la Grèce ne veulent plus
accueillir ou pas accueillir tous les
migrants qui se présentent les pays
d'origine des migrants ne sont pas
coopératifs pour
récupérer ceux qui ont transité sur leur
pays et les passeurs se foutent des
réglementations alors on a une impasse
aujourd'hui qui est politique
sécuritaire et socio-économique pour
restreindre les arrivé de migrants sur
deux points précis je voudrais avoir
votre avis François eran au sein de
l'espace Schengen et pour en protéger
l'accès est-ce qu'il est possible et
acceptable aujourd'hui d'ériger des
barrières de sécurité de surveillance
des murs en quelque sorte à la fois sur
terre et sur mer alors on en a déjà un
qui est qui sont les dizaines et
dizaines de kilomètres de de haute
clôture barbelé dans le calési il faut
ut y aller il faut voir ça c'est très
impressionnant ça a pris une extension
énorme donc les Anglais soustraitent le
contrôle de leurs frontières à au
français qui sont piégés par une série
d'accords ça ne marche pas le nombre des
traversés de de small boats comme disent
les Anglais de petites embarcations n'a
cessé de progresser alors que la la
défense
physiquees clôtures sont de plus en plus
impressionnante ça ne marche pas et et
donc on peut toujours multiplier le
nombre de policiers de gendarmes ajout
des drones aux clôtures et cetera il
faut se demander pourquoi ça ne marche
pas mais la France alors c'est on fait
une politique étrange dans le calési
c'estàdire que on fait tout pour garder
chez nous des migrants qui veulent aller
à l'étranger c'est très étrange quand on
y pense hein et puis deuxièmement nous
faisons nous demandons à l'Italie
qu'elle fasse la même chose que nous
vis-à-vis de l'Angleterre et puis les
Italiens aimeraient bien que les
Tunisiens fassent preuve de la même
docilité ou B vénement et cetera ou la
Libye donc on a et c'est ce que
j'écrivais dans un éditorial hier on a
l'Europe est stée par une série de
défausses qui vont toujours du nord au
sud et ça ne marche pas aucune de ces
frontières ça ne marche je connais très
bien le brillan sonnet la frontière
italienne ça existe pour les pays qui
sont en Europe centrale et oriental oui
alors il faut quand même il faut quand
même savoir que les pays d'Europe
centrale et orientale la Hongrie la
Pologne la Slovaquie ce sont pas des
pays attractifs ce sont des pays
d'émigration et pas d'immigration ce
sont des pays qui perdent de leur
population la Hongrie est redescend vous
prenez la Pologne aujourd'hui elle a
1500000 Ukrainiens oui ce sont des
Ukrainiens non non non il faut on se
trompe toujours à ce sujet non on se
trompe toujours à ce sujet ce ne sont
pas des immigrés permanents ce sont
c'est la main d'Urre attendez je termine
ma phrase c'est de la main d'ordre
provisoire que et et les et les les
Ukrainiens n'acceptent pas les les
Polonais n'acceptent pas que les
Ukrainiens puissent avoir des séjours de
moins un an qui on ferit de véritables
immigrés donc quand vous regardez la
véritable durée du séjour qui définit
l'immigration qui est au moins un an il
n'y a quasiment pas vous venez de dire
que les pays oui vous venez de dire que
les pays se défossent et que les murs ne
fonctionnent pas mais alors est-ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec la décision
européenne de faire une surveillance
beaucoup plus forte au niveau maritime
alors ça serait quelque part un mur
maritime le pacte européen des des
migration c'est ce qui a été récemment
décidé non non non non il n'est pas
encore décidé ils en en parler non mais
permettez que je précise connaît très
très bien cette affaire donc c'est pour
l'instant la commission européenne qui a
qui a défini un projet provisoire à la
grande surprise des parlementaires qui
n'avaient pas été prévenus ça doit
encore dans la procédure européenne être
validé par le Parlement européen et être
validé par le Conseil par l'ensemble des
responsables de gouvernement on en est
pas encore là donc pour l'instant
provisoirement si ce Pact est appliqué
il y a effectivement un contrôle aux
frontières c'est en fait le renforcement
du système Dublin c'est un contrôle au
pays de première entrée d'une part il y
aurait aussi et c'est ce qui a été
négocié entre les par la Commission
européenne chaque pays pourrait
contribuer non pas en prenant sa part
des immigrés en fonction de sa
population et de sa richesse comme
c'était ce que le plan Junker avait
prévu mais donnerait une part variable
on pourrait accueillir des personnes
envoyer des experts envoyer de l'argent
pour accepter ou rejeter les migrants et
ainsi la Hongrie et la Pologne pourrait
participer au système c'est pas encore
acceptépppp à ce qui vient d'être dit
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est
réalisable ces murs à la fois avant que
les migrants n'arrivent et qu'est-ce que
vous pensez d'un contrôle maritime qui
serait plus étroit on appelle ça on a
appelé le Mur de l'Atlantique et bon ça
pourrait s'appeler le mur de la
Méditerranée par exemple non mais je
pense que non seulement c'est réalisable
même si c'est difficile mais surtout
c'est nécessaire c'est ce qui se passe
dans le calésie précisément c'est que ce
que fait l'état français ce à quoi
servent nos impôts c'est qu'ils
empêchent les migrants qui qui sont le
fruit de trafic organisé savemment et de
façon toujours plus lucrative par les
passeurs qui sont organisés avec des
filières très lucrative he aujourd'hui
c'est beaucoup plus rentable de faire du
trafic de migrants que de faire du
trafic de drogue donc ce que font les
passeurs c'est que il les amène au bord
de la plage là et puis juste avant de
passer vers la Manche et que il se
dépêche je l'ai vu oui non mais je sais
secondesz laiss-moi raconter pour en 30
secondes il gonfle les bateaux il se
précip P pour vite aller en mer et donc
il faut leur jeu c'est d'éviter de se
faire interpeller tant qu'ils sont sur
le sable donc pour les gendarmes c'est
très difficile et que fait que font les
gendarmes et les policiers dès qu'ils
prennent la mer ils viennent les sauver
pourquoi parce que tous ces hommes et
ces femmes risque de mourir en mer et
donc moi je suis quand même fière
d'appartenir à un pays où on empêche des
femmes des enfants des jeunes hommes de
se noyer dans la Manche ilut
jugerés ça veut dire que la question la
question de la politique migratoire et
ce dans quoi l'État français intervient
c'est des conventions internationales
c'est aussi la protection des plus
fragiles et oui ça passe par en effet le
fait d'éger des protections maritimes
pour éviter que oui des hommes et des
femmes ne se noient en mer parce que ça
fait partie aussi de tout un système et
donc dire on ne peut rien faire il faut
laisser les passeurs continu à faire
leur trafic n pas dit ça ça heurte
honnêtement laiss laissez-la intervenir
et vous aurez juste unote juste un mot
plus on ferme plus on ferme les
frontières plus r l'état franais plus on
ferme plus on ferme les frontières plus
on enrichit les passeurs si Monsieur
siti Madame Le Pen arriv au pouvoir les
premiers à se frotter les mains seraient
les passeurs et relèver et relèver leurs
tarifs parce que les risques vont
augmenter et ils vont encore s'enrichir
alors c'est c'est c'est pas
pas en cours si vous voulez bien écoutez
c'est quand même très important c'est
deux questions important tente cet
espace Schengen aujourd'hui on parle de
mieux le contrôler par des frontières
maritimes des frontières à la fois
terrestres et maritimes qu'est-ce que
vous en
pensez bon d'abord euh moi je suis pas
spécialiste de droit européen mais je
constate que certains pays dans le monde
comme le Japon euh qui se trouve face à
la plus grande puissance démographique
mondiale n'a pas d'immigrants les
Chinois il y en a plus en France qu'au
qu'au Japon
si j'étais chinois j'essayerais
d'immigrer au Japon ça serait plus
facile c'est le parler écoutez ne soyez
pas juge des propos de chacun écoutez il
faut que ce soit un débat si c'est pas
un débatux bien une for imigration au
Japon qui'est quand même pas très
ancienne et qui est pas très connue
pardonnez-moi de vous le dire j'ai
enseigné pendant des années le des cours
d'histoire de géographie du Japon le
Japon est une société qui fonctionne la
forme de stage qui se répète d'année en
année dissimulé sous la forme de stage
qui se répète d'année en année c'est
pour ça que ça concerne davantage les
Coréens que les chinois mais on pourrait
imaginer qu'il y ait 100 millions
d'immigrants chinois ou asiatiques au
Japon c'est pas le cas c'est pas le cas
il devrait y avoir ça parce que si vous
voulez c'est la région le pays le plus
riche de l'Asie et du monde pendant il y
a encore quelques années c'est plus le
cas maintenant ils ont notre niveau de
vie donc voilà ils sont exactement comme
nous en terme de niveau de ville Japon
ils sont face à des masses
démographiques qui il y a deux pays de 1
milliard d'habitants en face de pas très
loin de chez eux et ils n'ont pas
d'immigration l'Australie alors bien sûr
ce sont des îles j'en conviens mais
l'Europe aussi est une île finalement
puisque tout si la population n'arrive
pas par la Russie une presquil disons
euh ça c'est le premier point le
deuxième point c'est que il faut bien
réaliser que le le produit de ces
migrations actuellement ce sont des soit
des états faillis alors les états
faillis c'est pas ce qui manque au sud
de la Méditerranée vous avez le Soudan
les deux Soudans vous avez l'Éthiopie en
guerre vous avez la Tunisie vous avez la
la Tunisie n'est pas un état failli mais
c'est un état très affaibli vous avez la
Libye qui est authentiquement failli et
vous avez maintenant le Mali le Niger et
cetera ces états ne vont pas euh se
ressaisir et prendre le contrôle de leur
territoire que je sache or vous savez
qu'aujourd'hui si on parle en
démographie générale vous avez j'ai
calculé 52 naissances en Afrique pour
une naissance en France donc vous avez
un déséquilibre euh Intercontinental
alors si on prend les au niveau de
l'Union européenne c'est un peu plus ça
doit être 8 naissan enfin toute l'Europe
réunie pour 52 en Afrique donc vous avez
un déséquilibre considérable vous avez
aussi des États qui ne satisfont pas
leur population on peut en parler
pendant des heures voilà vous avez donc
des masses de jeunes gens parce que la
moyenne d'âge en Afrique est très très
jeune je crois que 60 à 80 % des
Africains ont moins de 25 ans donc c'est
c'est à C âge là qu'on part c'est pas 70
ans bon donc à ce agege- là on a des 1
milliard d'habitants qui ne veulent pas
évidemment tous partir mais ça se compte
par 10 dizaines et dizaines de millions
de gens qui veulent partir pour tenter
leur chance donc soit on dit bah ok on a
les moyens de de les intégrer et même si
on les a pas on y va soit effectivement
il faut faire une une situation de
contrôle d'une manière ou d'une autre
parce que si vous voulez d'abord comme
je disais il y a d'autres exemples dans
le monde de de cette résistance
complexe mais surtout sinon on change de
je dirais on change de de modèle on
change d'économie on change de pays de
langue de civilisation c'est possible
hein oui alors Xavier RC j'aimerais
avoir d'autant plus votre point de vue
que vous connaissez bien vous avez été
ambassadeur en Algérie on a des
problèmes aujourd'hui avec la Tunisie
comme on en a eu avec la Turquie en
voulant
sous-traiter l'immigration mais en même
temps les propositions AFF fluent de
partout en disant qu'il faut contrôler
ces migrants avant qu'ils atterrissent
en Europe est-ce que ça vous paraît
gérable réalisable je vais revenir aussi
sur le h précéd vous me permz je vous en
prie euh j'ai pas mal évolué là-dessus
par ma pratique de ces questions là par
les 8 années que j'ai passé en Algérie
par aujourd'hui ce que la pratique de la
cour du droit d'asile où je siège et
comme tout diplomate je dirais j'étais
ou je suis plutôt proeopéen assez
libéral et cetera mais je pense
aujourd'hui on ne pourra pas s'empêcher
de remettre en cause une bonne partie de
nos acquis ou de notre système même
Schengen vous parliez de Schengen tout à
l'heure je pense que Schengen
correspondait à une époque le grand
marché unique la libre circulation des
produits et des hommes et des femmes que
aujourd'hui dans le contexte dans lequel
nous sommes on ne referait pas Schengen
en clair donc je pense que l'Europe
n'échappera pas à une remise en cause
d'un certain nombre de principes je
pense également que ce n'est pas
uniquement bloquant la Tunisie ou les
Afghans vers la Grande-Bretagne que ça
marchera je crois qu'il faut on ne
pourra pas non plus contrôler totalement
l'immigration ce n'est pas possible je
pense qu'il faudra un patchwk de mesures
des mesures d'ordre diplomatique des
mesures internationales des mesures
d'ordre réglementaire des mesures
d'ordre législatif ce n'est pas la loi
prochaine qui va régler le problème ne
soyons pas naïfs des mesures d'ordre
social et cetera il y aura un l'ensemble
de mesures que les pays européens que la
France notamment doit penser ce qui a
d'ailleurs le cas sur Schengen puisque
depuis 2015 à cause de la menace
terroriste en fait on est revenu et on a
les usages ont réétabli le cont contrôle
aux frontières intérieures de
l'espaceeng moi j' encore plus loin je
pense qu'aujourd'hui la libre
circulation à l'intérieur de l'espace
Schengen pour les non européens c'est
une aberration c'est François erand
là-dessus sur ce point connais que je
peux choquer je suis assez d'accord avec
ce que dit Monsieur l'Ambassadeur à
savoir que c'est un patchwork de de
mesur qui va être nécessaire le la
politique des murs va dans le mur si
j'ose dire elle est elle s'est avéré
totalement inefficace que ce soit la
frontière franco-italienne à la
frontière franco-britannique à la
frontière également basque et cetera
plus on multiplie les gendarmes et les
policiers plus le nombre des passages
augmente ce qui montre qu'il faut il
faut voilà alors il faut réfléchir à des
mesures c'est plus compliqué c'est sûr
c'est c'est tellement plus simple de
doubler le nombre de gendarmes donc
voilà ensuite je effectivement il y y a
il y a tout le problème diplomatique
c'estàdire que les pays qui génèent à
peu près 80 % des des demandeurs d'asile
ou des des des demandeurs de refuge pour
dire les choses plus largement dans le
monde c'est 5 6 7 pays hein c'est un
tout petit nombre de pays c'est très
concentré on a cité le Soudan mais c'est
bon euh et et regardez par exemple la le
pays le plus représenté parmi les les
gens qui sont présentés à le banglad à
lampedouza c'est la Guinée non c'est la
Guinée mais la Guinée qui entre
parenthèses et le seul pays à avoir voté
non en 1958 à la communauté oui je pense
que franchement je ne pense pas que ça
je pense pas que ça a un rapport je
pense pas que ça a un rapport je crois
qu'en réalité ce qui passe en Guinée
c'est qu'il y a 2 ans il y a eu un coup
d'État il y a une situation de violence
extrême il y a un très grand nombre de
de violences qui sont commises par des
hommes en uniforme et donc les gens
cherchent pas l'Eldorado il cherche
simplement à pouvoir développer un
projet simple et et avoir une minimum de
sécurité vous constatez quand même qu'au
niveau des pays européens y compris les
plus démocratiques comme les pays
nordiques on une volonté aujourd'hui des
peuples des états des gouvernants de
restreindre l'immigration est-ce que
vous contestez cette chose non non mais
je ne conteste absolument pas j'en ai
j'en ai parlé très souvent y compris
dans mes cours dans mes tribunes je je
cité récemment le cas de la Suède la
Suède était longtemps la le premier pays
d'Européen qui répondait tout de suite
qui répondait tout de suite aux demandes
du HCR du Haut- commissariat au réfugiés
pour accueillir des éitréens des afghans
dont personne ne voulait et ce C dans
les dans les années 2012 2013 2014 avant
la fameuse crise des migrants ils ont eu
ils ont été lassés de de de jouer les
bons élèves tout seuls et ils se sont
arrêtés alors non pas de en 2015 comme
je l'écrit dans la tribune du Monde il
une coquille en 2017 avant même les
avant même les Allemands avant l'accord
des Allemands AC Erdogan ils ont cessé
donc parce queil faut qu'il y ait
effectivement une juste répartition de
l'effort de la charge entre les pays
européens donc il faut dire qu'ils ont
une politique migratoire et
d'intégration beaucoup plus efficace que
la nôtre c'estd que d'abord ils ont
accueilli beaucoup plus en proportion
ils en ont 1 million sur une une
population qui tourne C 11 millions mais
surtout ils mettent beaucoup d'argent
sur l'apprentissage de la langue sur
l'emploi ils ils trouvent tout suite un
emploi pour les migrants qui ont tout de
suite le droit de travailler et un
logement c'est vrai que ce sont des
éléments très vous avez raison
d'insister làdessus sont des éléments
très importants et aussi le cas du
Danemark qu'on cite beaucoup qui qui
sert de modèle à certains donc on une
social démocratie qui donne des gages à
l'extrême droite pour garder le pouvoir
et mais alors le problème du Danemark
c'est que c'est un pays qui a un seul
grand voisin terrestre qui s'appelle
l'Allemagne 14 fois plus peuplé et donc
c'est une politique de défausse de tir
au flanc de de free rider comme dis
l'économiste de cavalier seul ils
peuvent se permettre de refuser les les
indésirables parce que l'Allemagne leur
porte
les acceptte c'est un peu ce que fait le
Canada avec les les États-Unis le Canada
peut se permettre d'être extrêmement
sélectif parce que les États-Unis 10
fois plus peuplés se charge d'accueillir
par exemple les Hispaniques dont les
Canadiens ne veulent pas donc c'est
important parce que des politiques qui
ne sont pas généralisables qui reposent
juste sur une rente de situation sur la
défaus visà-vis d'un d'un puissant
voisin beaucoup plus intégrateur ben par
définition ce sont pas des politiques
généralisables on peut pas les importer
dans un grand pays comme la
[Musique]
France
je vous soumets cette cette citation de
Jean-Louis borlau reprendre le contrôle
du peuplement et quelque chose qui
peut-être partagé voyez ce contrôle du
peuplement d'après la Banque mondiale
l'immigration serait un moteur de
prospérité et de développement c'est
d'autant plus vrai que nous manquons de
travailleurs dans de nombreux secteurs
de l'économie est-ce qu'on peut procéder
à des quotas choisis et faut-il pour
autant régulariser les immigrés
travaillant dans les secteurs dit en
tenstion cela dit alors que près de
400000 immigrés en France actuellement
en situation régulière sont en chômage
hierver muren ce sont des choix
politiques si vous voulez on a un
problème de en médecine en France he on
manque de médecin on manque d'infirmière
et
cetera on en a quand même deux à trois
fois plus qu'en Afrique pour les pays
les plus avancé d'Afrique je pense
notamment au pays du Maghreb or pour
combler et pour des raisons légitimes
ont fait venir des milliers l'année
dernière plusieurs milliers de médecins
d'Algérie il y a 15000 ou un peu plus
médecins marocains qui exercent en
France et donc si vous voulez en
aggravant la situation de la santé dans
ces pays on a et donc c'est des pays
faut réaliser où la sécurité sociale est
extrêmement modeste elle est
pratiquement réservée aux fonctionnaires
et au cadre des grandes sociétés donc
elle n'existe pas donc l'essentiel c'est
la médecine publique si la médecine
publique qui est déjà deux à trois fois
moins bien doté que la nôre en en en
spécialiste en médecin pour les
infirmières pour les équipements c'est
infiniment moindre et que on déshabille
ces les hôpitaux du Maghreb à notre
profit on aggrave la situation et on
intensifie de ce fait le départ et la
volonté de partir de populations qui
veulent vivre normalement et parmi les
choses qui font qu'on vit normalement
c'est que si on est malade on espère
être soigné voilà donc il y a c'est un
choix politique si vous voulez et
aujourd'hui c'est répandu alors les
élites du Maghreb très souvent viennent
se faire soigner en Europe parce
qu'elles en ont les moyens et parce
qu'elles ont davantage confiance dans la
médecine qui est la nôtre c'est c'est un
fait moi ma femme a accouché au au Maroc
et tout le monde lui a dit mais quelle
drôle d'idée d'accoucher au Maroc alors
que vous pourriez aller en France nous
on va accoucher en France ça c'est c'est
c'est une expérience vécue mais pour les
classes populaires qui n'ont aucune
chance de se faire se faire soigner
ailleurs que dans des bonnes conditions
bah à ce moment-là l'immigration est une
vraie solution mais et là il faut qu'on
soit cohérent est-ce que il serait pas
plus simple d'ouvrir les vannes de la
formation en médecine chez nous parce
qu'on a dit qu'on a mis fin au numérus
closus en réalité on l'a pas fait on l'a
fait dans des toutes petites proportion
qui vont rien résoudre et donc on est
tributaire de médecins formés à
l'étranger dans des pays où la médecine
est est très faible
ou pour les secteurs enenstion qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez moi je pense qu'il il
y a deux leviers dans la politique
migratoire il y a le stock ceux qui sont
là et puis il y a le flux sur le stock
les 600000 clandestins qui sont en
France aujourd'hui dont on dit que ces
600000 là pourrai résoudre nos
problématique de métier en tenstion dans
le bâtiment dans l'aide à la personne et
ca ces 600000 ils sont là ils sont pour
beaucoup expulsable ni régularisable et
c'est la circulaire Vals qui s'applique
autrement dit au terme de 5 ans de de de
de travail dans des conditions
régulières et cetera où ils payent leurs
impôts on peut les régulariser tout cela
moi je pense qu'il faut oui les
régulariser en appliquant les textes
actuel les préfets peuvent aujourd'hui
grâce à la circulaire Val s'en
régulariser ils le font à hauteur de
100000 par an donc oui il faut les
régulariser pourquoi parce que de toute
façon on ne les reconduira pas à la
frontière vous connaissez comme moi les
problématique de reconduite à la
frontière qui sont à la fois très chèes
et qui sont pas opérationnelles et deux
oui il se trouve qu'il travaille qu'il
réponde à un besoin économique et que je
vois pas au nom de quoi on se priverait
de la valeur ajoutée ça c'est pour le
stock maintenant pour le flux ça ne vaut
de dire ça c'estàd de dire il faut
régulariser que si vous êtes très clair
sur vos conditions de régulation des
flux entrant et c'est là qu'il faut tout
changer c'est là qu'il faut être
beaucoup plus opérationnel sur qui on
accueille et dans quelles conditions et
puis aussi dans quelle proportion il
faut qu'il ait à la fois ce message
d'humanité sur la régularisation mais
quand même de fermeté sur la maîtrise et
avec beaucoup d'humilité parce que vous
avez raison on résoudra pas les flux et
on contrôlera pas tout mais à un moment
donné il faut que la la nation
démocratique c'est un choix entre nous
entre citoyens il faut qu'on dise ce
qu'on est prêt à faire et comment on est
prêt à accueillir ce qui arrive on n'est
même pas capable aujourd'hui de traiter
correctement et avec humanité les
immigrés qui sont sur notre sol français
et qui pour beaucoup sont quand même
discriminés et qui n'ont pas accès au
minimum de service public justement fr
sur la circulaire Vals je crois qu'il
est important de rappeler que la
circulaire Vals n'a pas une grande
valeur contraignante on ne peut pas en
faire état devant les tribunaux par
exemple quand il y a un contentieux la
circeval c'est juste des recommandations
au préfet en disant voilà vous allez
appquer la valeur d'une circul oui vous
allez appliquer tel et tel critères et
le Conseil d'État a fait un rapport sur
le le droit flexible où il examine le
statut la circulaire Vals il se réjouit
en disant que les préfets devront
désormais harmonisé leurs critères mais
en réalité c'est pas ce qui se passe car
il y a eu toute une série de rapports de
la Cour des comptes les rapports fait au
moment de la LOLF de l'an dernier qui
ont montré que 1/ers des préfets
n'appliquent pas la circulaire Vals un
tiers des préfets considèr que même si
un dossier a été remis en bon etu forme
bah au bout de 5 ans ils ont toujours
pas de début de traitement parce qu'il
considèrent que ils n'ont pas les moyens
les les moyens des préfectures l'emploi
des préfectures c'est un rapport la Cour
des comptes a diminué de 14 % en 10 ans
et les bureaux du séjour les bureaux de
l'asile ont été particulièrement frappés
et donc du coup les préfets pas
nécessairement par idéologie hein
simplement par contrainte sous
contrainte euh disent à leurs agents ben
écoutez donnez la priorité au
renouvellement des titres de séjour et
pas à l'admission exceptionnel le séjour
c'est-à-dire au régularisation et donc
on a une rupture d'égalité entre les
territoires qui est considérable qui est
tout à fait étonnante et donc la loi
d'armanin ce que propose la loi
d'armanin le volet travail de la loi
d'armanin c'est d'introduire les
critères de la circulaire Vals dans la
loi de faire en sorte que ce ne soit
plus un examen au cas par cas qui serait
qui dépendrait à la fois du bon vouloir
de l'employeur et du bon vouloir du
préfet mais que ce soit un examen au fil
de l'eau sur critères alors il faut
définir ces critères et moi je suis tout
à fait d'accord sur l'idée qu'il faut
définir très rigoureusement ces critères
il faut quand même aussi pouvoir
stabiliser les populations et à ce
moment-là euh l'employeur par exemple ne
pourra plus s'opposer à la
régularisation et le préfet ne sera pas
mis devant des choix impossibles
vous êtes en faveur de la régularisation
pour les métiers en tension je suis en
faveur de la régularisation pour les
métiers en tension parce que je pense
que la philosophie zéro régularisation
est tout aussi réaliste que la
philosophie zéro immigration si vous
voulez le de le statut de la de de de la
lutte contre l'immigration clandestine a
été fortement marqué par le Conseil
constitutionnel en 2013 c'est une
contribution à l'ordre publique a une
valeur constitutionnelle très bien mais
si vous laissez si vous faites une
philosophie zéro régularisation et que
vous arrivez à la mettre en pratique le
nombre des irréguliers continuera
d'augmenter et et du coup du couputre
forme de désordre d' sur les cotas je
pense qu'on emploie ce cette formule on
va mettre en place une politique de
quotas mais il faut savoir ce que
exactement ça veut dire c'est-à-dire ça
va être des des quotas effectivement par
catégories
socio-professionnel ou par groupes
familiaux ou autres ça veut dire que on
a besoin de je sais pas 20000 médecins
cette année le 21e000 qui va se
présenter on lui dira non attendez votre
tour l'année prochaine donc c'est
extrêmement compliqué à mettre en œuvre
une politique de quota les Américains le
font avec un système de point le Canada
également mais est-ce que dans une
Europe dont la politique migratoire est
quand même largement une politique
communautaire européenne est-ce qu'on
est capable de mettre en place une
politique de côta bien ver muren je vais
vous donner la parole mais je voudrais
ajouter un point que vous pourrez
préciser à propos de cette
régularisation d'immigrés pour les
métiers en tension est-ce qu'à votre
avis c'est une poudre aux yeux électoral
et politique au regard de la situation
actuelle où il y a des centaines de
milliers d'immigrés en situation
régulière qui sont au chômage qu'on a
connu des violences dans les banlieux et
que ces jeunes ne sont pas véritablement
intégrés est-ce que par rapport à ça si
vous voulez on essaie de comment dire de
faire du en même temps non on est on est
dans une situation économique assez
catastrophique si vous voulez c'est vrai
que le débat juridique est découplé oui
juridique et du droit du travail il est
découplé de la situation économique euh
c'est ce que je disais tout à l'heure
mais dans des proportions considérables
on a un des taux d'emploi les plus
faibles par rapport à l'Allemagne on a
un taux d'emploi ridicule à vérité ça ne
concerne pas que les immigrés
effectivement comme vous l'avez dit il y
a 400000 imigré légaux au chômage mais
en réalité le taux d'emploi des Français
et des populations immigrées en
particulier de certaines régions est
très faible donc oui il y aurait des
réservoirs de travail mais d'abord il y
a un manque de travail très important
pourquoi est-ce que le patronat
s'accroche à cette catégorie des métiers
en tension parce qu'il faut accepter des
gens très peu payés dans des métiers
très pénibles et dans des villes très
chères et donc si vous voulez
effectivement c'est un beau cadeau qu'on
fait de d'avoir besoin de gens qui
viennent des pays les plus misérable du
monde pour leur donner les travaux
pénibles dans et puis loger dans des
foyers collectifs sans aucune sans aucun
confort à des horaires parfaitement
nocturnes le plus souvent ou commençant
très tôt le matin bon ça supposerait de
réfléchir à la question du logement
pourquoi est-ce qu' il y a des millions
de personnes en France qui ne
travaillent pas ou qui pourraient
travailler et qui ne viennent pas dans
les métropoles et notamment en île-
de-fance parce que le logement il est
inabordable et ça c'est pareil on dit
actuellement les banques ne prêtent plus
la construction est est très en
difficulté et en même temps 500000
personnes à peu près rentrent chaque
année en France donc vous créez les
conditions de la tension de l'inflation
sur les logements voyez c'est global
c'est pour ça que la question juridique
bien sûr dans un état de droit elle est
centrale mais si on pose la question
économique vraiment sur la table on se
dit qu'est-ce que c'est que cette
histoire de métier en tension de 3 ou 4
ou 500 ou 600000 personnes dans un pays
où il manque par rapport à l'Allemagne
100 millions d'emplois donc c'est la
question économique et notamment de la
production et centrale si les gens ne
travaillent pas en France ne veulent pas
travailler alors qu'ils sont là et queil
y a du travail c'est peut-être que le
problème il est ailleurs alors il est
peut-être culturel il est peut-être dans
le logement il est peut-être dans les
allocations il est peut-être dans
beaucoup de choses mais on pourrait
aussi réfléchir comme ça alors xaved Dr
encour vous avez choqué en publiant un
livre sur vos mémoires en Algérie bon
vous avez ça pouroi des mémoir oui mais
enfin c'est une photographie dealérie
une photographie mais vous allez voir où
je veux en venir euh la voix du
référendum pour traiter de l'immigration
est-ce qu'elle vous paraît souhaitable
puisqu'elle a été évoquée également par
Emmanuel Macron mais il faudrait
modifier la Constitution et en même
temps je voulais vous poser cette
question vous avez vous avez proposé de
dénoncer le traité signé avec l'Algérie
en 68 qui facilite l'entrée sur le
territoire français de travailleurs
algériens accompagnés de leur famille
est-ce que vous pers insister dans vos
intentions et en même temps aborder à la
fois la question référendaire et la
question de l'algé sur l'accord
franco-algérien j'ai été clair j'ai
publié non seulement dans mon livre mais
ensuite une note à la Fondapol sur la
question de de l'accord franco-algérien
en disant qu'il fallait le renégocier on
a tenté à plusieurs reprises mais on n'a
jamais rien obtenu avec un dans le fond
un délai ou un ultimatum pour dire aux
Algériens on remet les choses à place
sur la table et puis si on n arrive pas
ben on le dénoncera sur mais qu'est-ce
qui va pas dans cet accord pourqui vous
vouliez qu'on le dénonce cet accord il
est dépassé et il est les traités
internationaux sont supérieurs à la loi
on une valeur constitutionnelle une
valeur juridique supérieure à la loi la
loi française la loi française oui mais
l'immigration est à la foisérie échappe
les Algériens échappent à la loi
française en matière d'immigration et
vous verrez dans le projet de loi qui va
paraître il y aura un article disant que
ce ces dispositions s'appliquent au pays
étrangers sauf aux Algériens qui sont
régis par l'accord de
1968 et sur un référendum je pense qu'il
faut pas poser une question sur
êtes-vous pour ou contre l'immigration
mais il faut avoir
quelques quelques encore une fois des
mesures précises d'ordre juridique
d'ordre diplomatique
d'ordre c'est un peu voilà oui je je
enfin ça va être ça va être un QCM
effectivement comme comme on a multiplié
les lois hein on connaît le chiffre
maintenant depuis 93 21 lois déjà sur
l'immigration donc ces lois sont
postérieures à l'accord avec l'Algérie
et du coup ne s'applique pas bon c'était
des lois qui ciblait sur vous êtes
favorable à ce qu'on revienne sur cette
loi vous c'est c'est sans incidence
vraiment importante parce que non non
non mais attendez vous permettez que je
je je développe donc parce que c'est en
fait ce sont des des lois qui ont
essentiellement ciblé les migration
familiale qui ont lutté contre les
mariages gris les mariages blancs qui
ont euh imposé par exemple la
possibilité qui finalement rarement
appliqué parce que c'est pas appliquable
une fois de plus pour les maires de
vérifier la la réalité de la vie
maritale et cetera et cetera donc
effectivement toutes ces choses qui ont
été rajoutées euh bétonnées par les lois
successives ne s'appliquent pas aux
Algériens alors c'est pas simplement
l'accord de 68 il me semble qu'il a été
quand même renégocié dans les années 80
que c'est la version de des années 80 84
je sais plus exactement qui voilà le
sole c'est oui mais votre point de vue
là-dessus vous êtes favorable à ce qu'on
revienne là-dessus je pense pas que ce
soit fondamental mais c'est vrai que je
mais globalement moi je suis favorable à
ce que la loi soit la même pour tous que
la loi soit la même pour tous sur le
territoire français je suis favorable au
fait que les taux d'accord de la CN Cour
nationale du droit d'asile soit
davantage égalitaire que et cetera et
donc c'est bien l'égalité on y est tous
attaché et c'est vrai que les les
exceptions les dérogations comme cell
qu'on a à Mayotte celle qu'on a en
Guyane et tout ça c'est ça devrait
disparaître après voilà c'est mais je je
pense pas que le cœur du problème soit
là Juliette meradel la voix référendaire
par rapport à l'immigration c'est un
tabou qu'on franchit je je pense que
c'est quand même un peu le miroir aux
alouettes parce qu'une grande partie du
droit du droit en matière migratoire
c'est du droit européen et donc c'est
une façon de se défausser à mauvais
esscian sur le citoyen français en lui
faisant croire qu'il aura les manettes
pour gérer une politique migratoire dont
on voit qu'aujourd'hui elle échoue
principalement en Italie parce que faute
d'accord entre les pays européens pour
se répartir la charge migratoire donc
c'est un peu une manière un peu
hipocrite et un peu facile de dire ah
benah on va s'en remettre aux citoyens
français à qui en fait il va falloir
ensuite expliquer mais bien sûr à qui
ensuite on on expliquera une fois que le
référendum sera passé bah finalement les
trois/art des questions sur lesquels on
vous a interrogé c'est pas nous c'est
l'Europe et il se trouve que nos
partenaires européens veulent pas
exemple typique aujourd'hui les pays qui
sont les plus assaillis en terme de
demande d'asile c'est la France
l'Angleterre l'Italie et l'Espagne et en
fait il se trouve que la charge
migratoire aujourd'hui certains pays
comme par exemple le Danemark refusent
d'en prendre leur part alors que ce
qu'il faudrait ça serait remettre au pot
toutes les demandes et les partager
entre les pays européens mais vous
comprz bien
aillesameon plèeu d'ailleurs pour le
rassemblement national que les solutions
toutes faites et démagogiques ne
marchent pas puisque même l'extrême
droite en Italie ne s'en tort pas et
qu'il faut donc un travail européen
sérieux pour se répartir la charge et et
ne certainement pas demander aux pauvres
citoyens français de décider alors que
évidemment que la France toute seule n'y
arrivera pasensemble vous êtes pas
favorable François je crois
effectivement que le référendum est une
une solution complètement illusoire ompe
les G le faisroire c'est prévu dans la
Constitution hein non mais 5è République
c'est prévu sur tous les sujets le
problème est de savoir est-ce que ça
peut marcher si on dit alors savoir
quelle question ce sera une question
binaire oui non alors que les problèmes
sont très compliqués mais laissons ça de
côté on va alors une fois supposons que
le référendum soit voté supposons que
les solutions les plus radical soit
appliqué que Monsieur STI Madame Le Pen
monsieur Zemour arrive au pouvoir et
cetera qu'est-ce qui va se passer ils
vont arriver à stopper drastiquement
l'immigration à inverser inverser les fl
et et alors si Monsieur alors si la
méthode mélonie ne marche pas la méthode
salvianie consistant à renvoyer tous les
bateaux on va les couler si jamais ils
reviennent tout ça illusoir il y a deux
solutions magiques qui sont illusoir
l'appel direct au peuple qui ne règlera
rien et le le côté on va être ferme
fermement ferme toujours plus ferme les
autres n'ont pas été fermes par quoi
c'est on a écouté votre point de vue
mais moi je voudrais oui app quand même
par l'évolution des points de vue de
gens comme Jacques Atal manuel Vals
Bernard couchner récemment qui sont
quand même des des docteurs de de de la
grande
foi libéral européenne et qui ont quand
même changé sensiblement leur point de
vue je suis d'accord avec vous sur cette
question de on peut pas se contenter de
de de mettre des des
rustines des sol it est-ce ça marche ça
marche pas ça marche pas peu importe ce
que
disent vous permettez on va terminer
cette émission sur la question politique
et chacun dira ce qu'il en pense depuis
quelques années voir quelques décennies
la politique française et la politique
nationale de très nombreux pays en
Europe centrale en Europe
orientale en Europe de l'Ouest et cetera
et parasité par la la question
migratoire et le chantage qu'elle peut
engendrer je voudrais que vous me disiez
chacun brièvement si cette question est
agitée comme un chiffon rouge pour
éviter l'extrême droite est-ce que ça
vous paraît réaliste et fondé est-ce que
les choses sont complètement imbriquées
c'est-à-dire l'immigration engendrant la
venue de l'extrême droite chacun avec
très peu de temps euh pierre vermuren
moi je si vous voulez c'est pas une
question de politique intérieure en
réalité il faudrait qu'on ait un état ou
des états évidemment si l'Europe
existait ça serait mieux si on éétait
pas endetté on serait aussi indépendant
on pourrait décider des choses mais
malheureusement c'est pas le cas mais je
crois qu'il faut à un moment on a des
interlocuteur au sud parce que la
réponse elle est au sud quand les
Allemands ont voulu arrêter la vague
migratoire ils sont allés voir les les
Turcs il leur ont dit combien vous
voulez ils ont fait un chèque de 5
milliards ça a à peu près bloqué
l'immigration sauvage en provenance de
Turquie qui voulait se débarrasser de
tous les Syriens qui était sur son sol
et il le cherche toujours à le faire
d'ailleurs euh quand euh Kaddafi benalii
euh le gouvernement algérien bouteflic
et cetera et le Maroc l'ont décidé à
certains moment les flux migratoires
étaient Taris à partir du moment où vous
avez des États qui décident de jouer le
rapport de force soit parce qu'on est
allé les détruire comme la Libye euh
soit parce que ils sont très faibles et
qu' sont investis par les mafias parce
qu'il y a le rôle de la mafia italienne
quand même en Sicile elle joue un rôle
considérable comme les mafias albanaises
et turques au Moyen-Orient ma des mafias
des mafias les mafias jouent un rôle
central elles gagnent des milliards
c'est le ce trafic est d'ailleurs ce qui
fait qu'on n' pas les populations les
plus dshéritées même si les gens
viennent des pays les plus dshérités ils
doivent payer entre 5 et 10000 € pour
venir ce qui sont des sommes
considérables
euh pour lesquels les familles se
cotisent en grand nombre d'ailleurs et
cetera donc après ça devient un enjeu
crucial pour eux
certes il faut s'entendre avec ces pays
il faut savoir ce qu'ils veulent il faut
savoir quel quel est le leur objectif et
et le négocier si on considère que c'est
comme la pluie effectivement on peut pas
empêcher la pluie je pense qu'on peut
empêcher l'migration mais il faut aller
à la source et parler avec les responsab
brièvement mais il nous reste très temp
TR phras la question migratoire elle est
ou elle a été instrumentalisé en
politique intérieure française
deuxièmement la question migratoire elle
est instrumentalisée par certains pays
le Maroc la Tunisie l'Algérie et cetera
et troisièmement il n'empêche qu'on ne
peit que c'est un sujet majeur en France
et en Europe aujourd'hui très bien je
vais vous donner la parole François
errand moi je pense que les vrais les
grands problèmes de notre société c'est
pas celui-là c'est le le changement
climatique c'est l'inlation c'est la
guerre en Ukraine c'est les les
superpissances c'est c'est les régimes
les régimes libéraux et et
enfin les Français eu même et les
français eux même ne pensent pas que
l'immigration soit le problème c'est
votre point de vue merci Juliette madel
sur cette question là ce n'est pas
l'immigration qui fait monter le
rassemblement national c'est la crise
sociale économique écologique et qui
conduit certains à désigner un bouc
émissaire avec l'étranger mais si nous
étions capables de résoudre l'état
dramatique des hôpitaux l'accès à
l'école qui se dégrade la crise du
pouvoir d'achat la pauvreté et
l'augmentation des inégalités sociales
nous n'aurions pas de menace d'un vote
d'extrême droite merci c'était aussi
votre point de vue écoutez il me reste à
vous présenter une bibliographie alors
Juliette madel vous avez publié un
impérieux besoin d'agir en deux mots
c'est quoi C c'est un c'est un livre
témoignage de de mon parcours de
militante de ma participation au
gouvernement et puis surtout des
propositions je voudrais juste qu'on
arrive à réhabiliter l'idée que l'État
et la puissance publique peut beaucoup
et que c'est l'une des fiertés de notre
pays évidemment dans une perspective de
solidarité et de République forte voilà
pierre vermeren histoire de la Algérie
contemporaine aux éditions du Nouveau
Monde
c'est avec l'Algérie ça ça change sans
changer oui mais ce que j'ai voulu faire
c'est un livre sur l'Algérie jusqu'à nos
jours parce que on l'Algérie ça ne
s'arrête pas en 62 et on serait très
bien avisé de s'intéresser à ce qui se
passe dans ce pays voilà alors François
erran vous avez publié migration et
société ça a été publié à la fois chez
Fayard et le Collège de
France
201 alors 201 V dernier livre c ok
immigration le grand dén voilà donc et
qui consiste à Ben à constaté que un un
certain nombre d'acteurs dans le débat
public grossissent des musurement
l'immigration pour pouvoir ensuite
justifier de la la réduire drastiquement
donc c'est ce paradoxe que que je je
décris et que mais il y a pas un accord
qui se fait sur les chiffres aujourd'hui
on arrive quand même à ah ben écoutez on
a maintenant des chiffres de qui sont de
meilleure qualité que entre l'OCDE
Eurostat lin et cetera tout ça on a on a
une qualité de voilà c'est ça qui que je
déplore c'est que effectivement dans le
débat public on a il y a très très peu
d'attention au fait et beaucoup plus de
démagogie que de pédagogie alors Xavier
dancour l'énigme algérienne chronique
d'une ambassade à
Alger c'est un retour d'expérience sur
les deux ambassades que j'ai eu que j'ai
fait en Algérie est-ce que vous restez
attach à l'Algérie oui voilà ben écoute
mais c'est un pays énigmatique qui vous
reste énigmatique même après 8 ans en
Algérie oui et je crois que même après
132 années pour beaucoup de Français ça
reste un pays éig c'est pour ça que
c'est très intéressant voilà ben écoutez
merci Madame merci messieurs d'avoir
animé à mes côtés cette émission qui est
pas simple hein parce que la question
migratoire nous en avons pour longtemps
merci à ipe de LCP qui réalise cette
émission il me reste à vous soumettre
cette pensée de thba de Montbrial nous
avons importé sur notre territoire des
les guerres ethniques du monde
[Musique]
entier